Vous êtes 7 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne YouTube
Pour fêter ça ...  Pizza !
NON !
Je réponds à vos questions que vous m'avez posé sur Twitter
Comme vous avez été quelques milliards à me la demander
Alors c'est cadeau !
Tu l'as embrassé comment ta première copine ?
Alors ... j'étais super à l'aise
Attends ... t'es sûr c'est comme ça qu'on embrasse ?
Bah bien sûr !
D'accord !
T'aimes bien être dans ton rôle de personnage dégueulasse et mono-sourcil, avoue.
Moi ? Non !
Ton smiley préféré que tu imitera avec ta tête bien sûr !
Vas-tu faire un one man show comme Norman, Le Woop ?
Ce n'est pas prévu, il faut savoir qu'un one man show ça demande beaucoup de temps
et je suis un branleur
Je préfère consacrer mon temps à réaliser ou à concevoir des petites vidéos, des courts métrages
je me sens plus auteur-réalisateur que standuper
tu sais faire combien de pompes ? Preuve vidéo
une
et deux.
Est-ce que tu t'es déjà pris un râteau quand tu étais au lycée ?
Oui ! Tu veux sortir avec moi ?
N'importe quoi Cyprien ! Si tu veux on peut devenir amis !
Non, ça je m'en fous. Je veux vraiment sortir avec toi en fait.
Tu vas refaire un court métrage ? Parce que le premier était génial.
Alors déjà merci beaucoup !
Ca m' fait plaisir parce que j'ai passé beaucoup de temps dessus
Et j'ai adoré ... euh ... bosser sur technophobe
Et je suis effectivement un train d'écrire un nouveau court métrage.
Je peux pas trop vous en dire euh ... beaucoup
mais ça sera une histoire d'amitié ...
sur fond de truc un peu geek ...
dans une période médiévale.
Non ça c'est pas vrai par contre.
Tu peux enlever ton tee-shirt en direct ?
Alors ok. Mais vous vous moquez pas d'accord ?
Voila ...
Voila.
Pas très glorieux hein ?
Quelle est ta meilleure technique de drague ?
Bonjour, c'est moi Cyprien.
Hum hum... moi je préfère le JDG et SLG.
D'accord
Et WTC, I ...
Ca va ! On a compris !
Quand tu fais des vidéos dans le style Snapchat, Twitter, Apple ne ferais tu pas du placement de produit ?
Alors j'adore cette question parce que ..
c'est vrai que sur internet on aime beaucoup le complot genre ....
On manipule en gagnant de l'argent.
Faut savoir que quand je fais une vidéo sur euh...
Top chef, Snapchat, Twitter, euh ... l'Apple watch
tout ça, ce n'est pas du placement de produit.
J'en parle parce que ça me fait marrer tout simplement.
Donc il faut arrêter d'être paranoïaque pour certains d'entre vous.
Il faut savoir qu'une marque ne donnera jamais d'argent pour qu'on détruise son produit.
Je vais dire que votre montre ne sert à rien, elle est chère, la batterie tient pas
et votre PDG se mouche avec des billets.
Génial !
Tenez 5000 euros.
Logique internet
Tes goûts musicaux ?
Alors mes deux groupes préférés
c'est Blur et Radiohead.
Grand fan.
Placement de produit pour des groupes ...
Ta gueule !
A quand une prochaine FAQ ?
Je fais quoi maintenant ?
Tu m'expliques ?
Peux tu faire une imitation de Squeezie et Norman ?
Et yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie. Aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur un simulateur de simulateur. C'est parti !
Oh, oh le jeu m'agresse directement
T'en penses quoi Jumbo ?
Ok Jumbo s'en fout d'accord
Faux
Pfff... C'est à croire que toutes les filles se sont mises d'accord.
Attends mais Norman t'es trop moche.
Ouais. T'as trop raison.
Super
Pourquoi tu ne filme plus dans ton appartement ?
Ah !
Vous avez remarqué ? hein ?
Effectivement je ne tourne plus dans mon appartement pour des raisons techniques
Puisque avant je tournais face à une fenêtre
qui donnait sur une rue passante
avec des motos et des voitures qui passent tout le temps
Et du coup j'étais obligé de parler quand les voitures ne passaient pas.
C'était très très chiant.
D'ailleurs je devais même parano
J'avais l'impression qu'il y'avait une moto qui attendait que je parle pour accélérer quoi
c'est ... je devenais fou
Je sais pas si
On ajoute à ça la lumière qui change tout le temps à cause des nuages qui passent
En plus je parle très fort quand je fais mes vidéos
du coup tout l'immeuble était énervé contre moi
Donc en fait pour vous comme pour moi
c'est mieux que je tourne ici dans des conditions un petit peu plus agréables
Vous avez des vidéos d'une qualité supérieure
Et puis comme je passe énormément de temps ici, en fait c'est un peu comme ma deuxième maison.
Voila.
Je fais mes montages, je fais mes trucs.
Ca sent la pizza
Ca te fais quoi de savoir que François Hollande te follow
Alors. Oui ! Oui !
François Hollande me follow
tranquillement, calme sur Twiter
Ca veut dire que je peux lui envoyer un message privé.
Wesh poto ! Ca fais quoi ce soir ?
J'espère avoir une réponse rapidement hein.
qu'on se fasse un petit Fifa.
entre potos
Quels sont tes futurs projets ?
Alors je travaille sur beaucoup de choses
un court métrage
et deux sketchs sur ma chaine youtube
euh j'écris aussi d'autres vidéos plus classiques
J'ai une série avec Norman de douze épisodes
une BD que j'écris en ce moment mais je vous en parlerai plus tard.
Bref.
J'ai pas mal de boulot.
Tu connais SLG ? Si oui tu peux faire une parodie ?
La vidéo qui va suivre date du 32 mai et montre un homme qui s'assoie sur des objets.
Mais pourquoi il fait ça ?
Il aimerait bien aller un petit peu plus loin si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Et il ne fera que ça pendant toute la vidéo jusqu'à ce que vos espoirs partent en fumée.
Ca je sais faire gros
Squeezie t'a dessiné magnifiquement bien. A ton tour de le dessiner lui.
Voila
Voila. Taille réelle.
Il est grand comme ça. Je le connais bien il est vraiment grand comme ça.
Quelle est la chose la plus bizarre qu'on t'ai dite ?
Une fois y'a un jeune qui m'a reconnu dans un magasin et il m'a dit
"Euh ... C'est toi Cyprien ?"
J'ai répondu : "Oui"
Puis il m' a dit : "C'est vrai ?"
Voila. Donc je sais pas si ...
Je devais me justifier peut être ?
"Si c'est moi. Regarde ... une photo je me ressemble..."
Si tu avais un clone comment tu le façonnerais ?
Ben il serait exactement comme moi.
Parce que c'est le principe du clone !
Il est pas con.
Es tu allé au Japon pour voir des hentais de qualité qui font plaisir ?
Pff...  N'importe quoi
C'est pas du tout mon genre hein de ramener des hentais de ...
Wahou
Pourquoi des nouvelles lunettes rondes ?
Ah. T'as remarqué ? C'est vrai que j'ai changé y'a pas très longtemps.
Les anciennes étaient mieux.
Quelle a été ta plus grosse betise quand tu étais petit ?
Alors quand j'avais 6 ans
j'ai piqué une grosse crise
parce que je voulais prendre un bain
et mes parents voulaient que je prenne une douche
Alors j'ai foncé tête baissée dans la porte vitrée du balcon
que j'ai brisé totalement
Voila et du coup mes parents m'ont donné une fessée
du coup j'avais mal aux deux extrémités.
Et, et puis j'ai pris une douche.
Que ferais tu si tu avais un Death Note ?
Alors un death note ça vient d'un manga
C'est un carnet où quand tu écris le nom de quelqu'un dedans
la personne meurt immédiatement.
Alors moi si j'en avais un j'écrirais le nom de pers...
Pourquoi tes vidéos font moins rire qu'avant ?
Si tu aurais pas été Youtubeur, tu aurais fait quel métier ?
Toi en tout cas, t'aurais pas fait prof de français.
Et voila c'est la fin.
Merci beaucoup !
Euh vous êtes des dingues hein
le hashtag #cyprienrepond est passé en training topics monde
C'est, c'est n'importe quoi, vous êtes des fous !
Et merci beaucoup de suivre ma chaine
et de me poser toutes ces questions
et de me suivre
Ca me fait extrêmement plaisir
7 millions c'est un truc de malade
Si vous êtes pas abonné, abonnez vous
Peut être qu'un jour on sera 8 millions
Peut être pas ...
Je ne sais pas. A bientôt
Un dessin que vous faites directement avec votre doigt
Ah, ils l'ont laissé ça ?
Les mecs j'avais dit qu'on le mettait pas ça